javascript has three kinds of pop-up
boxes
alert box confirm box and prompt box
many people think you should almost
never use this feature of javascript
preferring custom modals instead
the reason for this is because they're
very obtrusive they lock the entire
browser and will take focus even if
initiated by an inactive tab
but there are still occasionally good
reasons to use them so it's they're good
to know about
so for instance right now we have the
alert here so if i run this
it's going to pop up i am an alert box
right here now you cannot choose where
the pop-up box is going to be that's up
to the browser that's another reason why
custom modals are often better because
you have more choice of where it's going
to appear in the browser so these alert
boxes are just to give a message and
then you hit ok to make the message go
away one example is if you want to give
a message that a person is just about to
be automatically logged out of a website
okay let's comment this out and we're
going to put another one here now i'm
going to show you the confirm box so
this is the code for the confirm box
you're going to put the word confirm and
then you're going to put what you want
to be confirmed and this is going to
return a
a boolean
so if if you if we run this to see what
it looks like
so we can now either push cancel or ok
if we put ok it will return true if we
put cancel it will return false so if i
click ok you'll see in the console you
pressed ok that comes from this right
here or if i run this again
and press cancel and the console say you
you press cancel
and just you know alert and confirm
these are all part of the window object
so you could write it like this
window.confirm or window.alert that's
implied if i run this it will do the
exact same thing
but the window is just implied when you
use alert or confirm
okay and the last one is the prompt
let me
comment this out for prompt you can pass
in two things the first is the message
that's going to show and the second
thing is the default text in the text
box
let me run this and so you can see what
i mean so in prompt you can actually put
in a piece of information here and then
it will return that piece of information
so you can see in this code it's person
is going to equal and it's going to set
the the variable person to equal
whatever we put in here so if we put we
can change this name
and then if i hit okay
you can see in the the con the
console.log hello quincy how are you
today and we just get it from here this
if person equals null or person equals
nothing then we're going to put user
cancel the prompt
else we're gonna say hello and we're
gonna bring in the person's name that we
used and then how are you today so if i
run that again
and hit cancel it's gonna say user
canceled the prompt okay that's pop-up
boxes
thanks for watching my name is beau
carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good